trente mille ouvrages horn
l'impressionnante bibliothèque d' aragon
et elsa triolet un héritage en danger dû
à l'humidité causés par les inondations
le mobilier les archives le bureau tout
a été endommagé voire ravagé par l'eau
plus de cent mille euros de pertes sont
à déplorer d'après l'association maison
elsa triolet aragon ici au clos et monte
vraiment jusque et jusqu'à ce niveau là
ici donc à toucher les premiers niveaux
des bibliothèques
déjà pendant la nuit et on les a
déménagé au plus vite au 6 mai donc ça a
touché des livres des livres rares ou
des la collection de vinyles de louis
aragon son avis on le tourne disque
d'aragon qu'il est de ce côté là on n'a
pas acheté de livres là les livres sont
conservés et on essaie de les soigner au
maximum on met des papiers buvard entre
entre les pages pour pour absorber
l'humidité on les change régulièrement
et ça a touché environ 250 livres ici
l'annulation des visites prévues lors du
mois de juin mois connaissant le plus de
fréquentation s'ajoute à la liste des
frais une aide rapide est sollicité les
dons sont déductibles à 66 % des impôts
pour les particuliers il ya des
assurances qui prendront certaines
choses en charge l'état va nous aider
aussi on l'espère mais on a besoin aussi
d'avoir un soutien rapide un petit peu
de nos amis que ce que qu'on nous montre
un petit peu de la solidarité pour le
lieu est un amour tu de cette maison
laissée par aragon et elsa triolet et
donc tout coup de pouce vraiment est le
bienvenu en ce moment 25 % de la somme
espérée a été récoltée dans les premiers
jours un bon espoir pour la suite
la maison d'elsa triolet aragon devrait
rouvrir au public le 3 juillet à
l'occasion du concert de sanseverino